if you want to hear all three of my
theories about Hospice then stick around
to the end of this video sponsored by
crook TV [ __ ] TV has just brought back
hospice the hospital ghost story that
originally haunted doctors and patients
in late 2017 so before we explore the
things you missed in the latest episode
let's revisit what happened back in
episode 1 Sharon is a nurse taking care
of a patient named mr. Noah who suddenly
sits up and starts suffocating next
thing we know his corpse is being taken
away and Sharon is pretty badly shaken
up by the incident the doctor gives her
the option to leave but she decides to
still work for night shift as the body's
taken away a marble falls off of the
stretcher and Sharon hold on to it later
that night one of her co-workers Jake
asked Sharon to cover for him as he
takes off 30 minutes early
leaving Sharon alone in the hospice mine
shortly after the lights start
flickering before Sharon is attacked by
the ghost of mr. Noah who cannot be seen
on the security camera footage when the
doctor eventually finds her body
he doesn't seem as shocked as he should
be not again
so episode 2 starts with a new nurse
named Alice Carol she's having some kind
of vision of a kid being attacked by a
monster we can tell from the symbol on
its head and the things that this is a
brute from the 4th monster universe
episode of the door in the woods which
is about four kids who accidentally
unleash this monster upon their Colin
Alyce's pulled out of the vision by the
sound of flatlining she reports on the
time of death 11:05 this doesn't match
up with the time we just saw on the EKG
machine which could either mean that
this is still part of the vision of the
kid being mauled by brutes or this is
just a small continuity error because
the day also doesn't match the day that
they put on the patient's morgue tag
either the doctor notices that she's
distressed and tells her you'll get used
to the dead at first he seems to be
referring to her getting used to
patients dying but on closer inspection
he could also be referring to the ghost
seen in the hospice war Alice offers the
wheel the patient down to the morgue
so her fellow nurse Barbara has Lee
gives her the instructions to take a
right at the end of the basement
corridor emphasizing to only go right
alice's curiosity leads her to go left
anyways after seeing the sign that it
leads to the hospice wing but she gets
caught pretty quickly
that wing is closed it is then why is
the door open with the lights on is
there some kind of presence trying to
beckon Alice into this forbidden
territory when Alice gets into the
morgue she startles the metal head
coroner who's cleaning up blood at the
time for arrival Alice notices a
mortuary cabinet labeled with the name
Kane and asked if this is dr. Kane's son
probably the same dr. Kane who owns this
hospital Dan tells her that the kid died
of heart disease which doesn't match up
with the visions or the fact that he's
cleaning up blood off the table when she
arrives though the blood theoretically
could have been from one of the others
Alice goes to investigate more about
Norman Kane but before she gets the
chance
Barbara shows up and warns her again to
stay out of the hospice wing back in the
morgue Kane's cabinet bursts open and
this monster emerges and throws Dan into
a transformer box causing lights to
flicker around the hospital I like how
there's actually a practical reason for
the lights flickering and it's not just
explained away by the hospital being
haunted this also ties back into the
flickering lights from the first episode
and that leads me to my first Theory
episode one takes place after the rest
of the season this can be supported by
the fact that the lights were never
fully fixed after episode 2 and the fact
that the doctor says not again after
discovering Sharon's body in the first
one the data on the security footage
from the first episode is November 10
just eight days after the death of mr.
Connelly in the first episode my second
theory is that Alice has psychic
abilities upon arriving at the hospital
for her first day she's able to see a
vision of Kane's son being killed and
she's even seen rubbing her forehead as
if she's focusing some kind of psychic
energy when she goes down to the
basement corridor she takes a left into
the hospice wing despite just being told
to go right I feel like there's
something from beyond that lured her to
go explore in that direction and she
also seems pretty quick to believe in
the supernatural when her and barber
discusses do yourself a favor
forget what you heard why
where the story is real then towards the
end of the episode she goes back to
explore the area again and it looks as
if she sees something at the end of the
hall but when we cut to the reverse
there's nothing there the second theory
leads into my third and final Theory
Alice's coworker Barbara is one of the
ghosts trying to lure Allison if Alice
is a psychic she'd be the only one who'd
be able to see Barbara there's no
interaction between dr. Evans and
Barbara in the opening scene I the ears
I'm hearing is I looked at you once
Barbara also gives oddly specific
directions for Alice to only turn right
at the end of the basement corridor it's
almost as if she wants to peek Alice's
curiosity and lure her into the haunted
went the other scene with Barbara is
again just the two of them and again
Barbara doesn't provide the specific
details about why Alice should keep out
of the hospice Wayne if you have any
theories about hospice and how it ties
into the other Crypt series be sure to
let me know in the comments and if you
haven't already make sure you're
subscribed to crypt TV for new scary
videos every Monday Wednesday and Friday
every Friday they upload a new chapter
to the Crypt monster universe so click
the link in the description so that you
don't miss out on any future
installments and as always I'll see you
in the next one assuming we both survive